phox are you just determining your
really schedule by throwing darts at a
dartboard now or what
[Music]
so says shifted its schedule again and
the most notable impact is to the x-men
franchises a Deadpool staying put but
everything else is moving and this is
not particles nuts about this this is
not the first time this has happened I
think I mentioned the movement of New
Mutants before when it happened because
I didn't think too much of it at the
time they or at least I didn't think
enough about it to get a videos worth of
material on it but the original release
date for New Mutants it was supposed to
be coming out April like this year like
we were supposed to be watching this
within the next few weeks so it was done
then I got bumped to February of 2019
and was going through some notable
reshoots apparently because they wanted
to integrate some new characters into it
which okay seems a little odd but okay
and now we've gotten the announcement
that that has been moved again to August
of 2019 which it's now being released
almost a year and a half from its
original release date and x-men Dark
Phoenix that was coming out this year I
think in November now it's February of
next year so what is going on that's not
like me even setting up for something I
genuinely do not know what the heck is
going on with this like the stories that
are coming out that I'm singing that I'm
reading are a lot of it's speculation
there was one piece that claimed that
it's because of reshoots but that cannot
possibly be all that's going on reshoots
are built into the schedules of these
movies they
plan for reshoots well in advance they
almost completely reshot Justice League
and frigging solo a Star Wars story
neither of those moved they didn't have
to and those were way more extensive
reshoots than were originally planned so
how is it that we have just oh you know
we just got to do some reshoots and
we're moving things out months year
after the original release date I'm a
couple with random ideas I'm not sure if
any of this hold water though it's hard
to imagine that in some way the Disney
acquisition of Fox is not an impact on
this but the problem there is it cannot
possibly be as simple as Disney said do
it different because the acquisition
isn't done it's not complete Disney does
not actually have control of Fox yet
they cannot directly control the Fox is
doing I think maybe what's going on and
even this could be a stretch maybe
what's going on is Disney I you know as
things are moving forward has gotten a
look at these as they are as in the
current state that they're in has had
some notes now they don't have control
of Fox they can't make them do this but
maybe Fox is going okay you know what
we'll adjust to that and do what you
want basically to grease the wheels and
make sure this whole thing goes smoothly
and and the transition happens as
smoothly as possible
honestly that I I don't even know how
much I believe that but it's kind of the
only thing I can come up with like
especially with New Mutants again that
one was done like completely I'm not
gonna say I'm shocked by Dark Phoenix my
expectation is somebody finally saw a
cut of Dark Phoenix went holy God this
is awful and they tried to get more time
to get this all sorted out that's me
I have no insider information on that I
just there's no possible way that x-men
dark Phoenix is gonna be any good so I
think boy what what are some other
possibilities in this well okay you know
what I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna speculate on 50 million
possibilities but I will say this I will
actually give credit to Fox that if this
is just reshoots even extensive ones and
they're moving the the dates out good
because that historically has not worked
out well when there have to be a ton of
reshoots but they don't move the date
that's why that's why the whole thing
with Superman's upper lip and Justice
League happened because not only because
of the the way things pan out could they
not shave his mustache if they'd had
more time to finish the effect they
probably could have CGI'd it off better
than they did I do think it is a good
thing that these things be allowed to
move if we actually need more time to
work them because it's not even just
recent history Fox itself has a rather
nasty history and regards all this this
is part of why x-men The Last Stand was
such a mess because the writers strike
happened and they made no adjustments to
to account for that they just plowed
ahead with the half-baked script that
they had or another example with Fox
alien 3 kept going through massive
rewrites they had they had a set built
for this massive conceptual planet that
they basically had to completely tear
apart cuz they change the core concept
of the movie and where it was gonna be
set but they wouldn't move the release
date so it's good that they are I still
don't buy that reshoots or all that's
happening this this is too much this is
too big I've been running through some
of this with some of my friends my
friend Ryan his theory and I don't
believe this but I'll throw it out there
and give credit to him so that you know
when he's inevitably wrong I don't get
heat for it but well Ryan things is
happening is that the the new character
being integrated into New Mutants is
cable to try and help set up for x-force
because in the comic books x-force it
was sort of the next evolution of New
Mutants which was the comic book that
Kable was originally introduced in in
the first place and on paper i can kind
of see that except that the latest
trailer for deadpool made it very
blatant that deadpool is setting up
x-force on its own it doesn't need to
set it up in New Mutants other rumors
that are coming in was that they want
they really wanted to really up the
scary they want new Muse to be a full-on
legit horror movie really make it scary
and and the reshoots and they're gonna
end up like reshooting about half of it
so between integrating a new character
and really wanting to up the the scare
quotient that might be what's going on
regardless the the rumor is that
director Daniel Boone is not thrilled at
having to go back and keep working out
he he reportedly was happy with the cut
that was gonna be released so it's
really just a mess and again it's hard
to imagine that this isn't in some way
either impacted by or a result of Disney
acquiring Fox because this level of
turmoil for what had been frankly a
stable franchise for a studio this is
not normal this is very atypical because
regardless of what I think about the
quality that yo-yos in terms of the
x-men films they have been a very stable
franchise so for them to be scrambling
like this left and right with stuff that
should be done should be finished and in
one case was it was done it was locked
it's just it really is like how much you
wanna bet between when I shoot this and
when I put this out which will be two
days after I shoot it that there will be
more details come out that make it clear
what the heck is actually going on
because that's just my luck right now
with the information we have all we've
got is everything's moving around and it
doesn't make sense like all I know is
like this is not typical this is not
normal I'd like to think it's not an
automatic condemnation of the film's I
mean mostly making my new muse
I say because like I said I have no
faith in x-men Dark Phoenix none
whatsoever but New Mutants I'm really
curious about I really want to see and
I'm gonna wait like a friggin year and
four months to see what the hell Fox the
hell yeah I could just be speculating
blindly if I want to from here I'm just
gonna cut it off at this point so Fox
moving the release dates for two x-men
films one of them for the second time
what are your thoughts on all this
whatever they are
yeah if they if you can make any more
sense out of this than I can I didn't
make much drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it do all the
stuff like maybe you support me on
patreon or follow me on Twitter listen
to my podcasts all of that stuff links
for this and more is down in the
description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]